what about american pie five i can't
tell you when because i don't really
know when because we have to put all the
actors at the same time
to get our schedules together yeah but
um there is a script out there i'll put
it that way
and have you i can't tell you anything
but you read the script
it's there did you enjoy the script were
you it's one of the best ones
yeah it's amazing so how do we make the
scheduling happen this is a big
deal this will happen i just don't know
when
okay but it will happen okay so
potentially this year potentially in
five years
and before five years i would i would
hope so but
unless you're gonna be like in 20 years
we're all gonna be in wheelchairs or
something like
is is there a story that you would love
to
see your your character i guess go
through a journey that you would like to
see her
i think i can't give too much today but
she will go through a journey and
her past will come up don't get mad at
me universal
you guys all stay in touch though you
guys yeah yeah
no not group text but we all like stay
in touch in different ways
yeah like natasha is one of my closest
friends i'm so proud of her what she's
doing right now
and just everyone everyone's in this
crisis is still
working which is almost impossible so
it's just
when you when you grow up with someone
and you get your first breaks with
someone
you can never forget that yeah you're
connected forever forever
tara reid good to see you great to see
you my friend we're here we're
celebrating cassie we're doing some
jazzercise at least you're doing
jazzercise i did not dress
for this i wasn't even i had an event
that i had to do yesterday and we're
staying at the hotel
the fairmont oh yeah yeah yeah but we
forgot that we had a
we're 80s here so this was just like
bikini cover-up
and this is the 80s convertible yes
how do you know cassie sharknado right
yeah do you guys stay in touch have you
stayed in touch
i love cassie other parents like
they're the coolest people ever yeah
cassie's is all heart
and you know this is all buddha bullying
i mean come on it's the right thing to
do
i know especially i think in these the
times they're in right now
people need love they do not need to get
bullied and i think this event is just
really
something that cassie and you know the
world really
and we all need we all need some love
right now i feel like you are a
hollywood icon
at this point but i know in hollywood
there are a lot of
uh mean girls mean people
have you ever experienced that and what
do you hope people can learn from any of
your experience obviously we all know
i've been uh bullied in my life
but i think you know through that
bullying
i i learned a lot you know it didn't
make me stronger and it made me
much more humble and kinder and i could
see when people do that easily
and it's it's the wrong picture the
wrong thing and then
everything's changed around and i just
feel like
you know people are alone by themselves
right now not everyone has a roommate or
a husband or whatever
yesterday i had to wear uh i had to do
another event and uh
it was the first time i wear heels and
were your feet today
no no it wasn't my feet my calves i feel
like
i don't even know what i can't explain
the pain because you're not you weren't
used to you're not used to it like i'm
wearing sneakers i'm like and i said to
my boyfriend i'm like
you know what i have to start wearing
like heels around the house again
because you get used to it
because i'm totally not it's been over a
year now you know i was gonna say i feel
like your
calves are probably amazing you look
incredible
is there a secret like what do i need to
know what should i be drinking
no i mean coconut water first of all oh
that's a big secret yeah it hydrates you
it's really good
okay and just trying to um stay busy
you know right now i'm producing um a
couple films my baby it's this movie
called masha's mushroom
and we have that put together and imdb
is like
10 different projects right now right
now so that was a great thing about this
in a certain way i kept myself busy and
instead of me
trying to get an offer for a movie i
created
these rules for myself i'm like you know
what if you're not gonna hire me
i'm gonna hire me yeah you know and that
i found the best directors and writers
and
we all came together and collaborated
and it's just been
a really good experience and it's your
baby now like literally
my baby yeah yeah you you mention your
boyfriend how's quarantine been
with him his name is nathan right yeah
nathan he's great
he's uh he has patience you know like
he does his thing like he's a producer
with music but he's also a mortgage
you know like oh so he's a mortgage
breaker and uh right now it's
huge and he was just hustling and it
made me proud
yeah to watch him you know and i was
working too
so sometimes we'd have to conflict and
get out of this stream and go in this
room because they're going to hear us
and zoom you know i know that too well
yeah
exactly right the working from home life
yeah it's good but sometimes you're like
i need a little space
yeah cassie said never say never to more
sharknados
could we see more i don't think so no
more no more
i've been a robot i gave birth inside a
shark
you know i mean i've done everything you
could possibly do i i don't see where
my character would go again okay but i
think we took a great
thing and we ran on it we did five films
yep
they all went great but sometimes you
know when i like hang up the flag and i
think we
ended it at a perfect being